[Music]
well you might as well start by writing
down that URL I'll show it to you again
at the end of class that's where the
syllabus is the syllabus will tell you
pretty much everything you need to know
about the class the there's a text this
is it it consists of readings from a
larger text I use it because it's old
but a lot of the theorists that we're
going to talk about are also old and so
I found this particular text accurate
and many of the people that we're going
to talk about are very a very
sophisticated views of personality and I
think that it does you a disservice
unless you read something that's
sufficiently sophisticated so that you
actually understand at least to some
degree what the people that were going
to study we're talking about we might as
well start I suppose with a definition
of personality it's hard to define
something that's that general because
when you're speaking about human beings
it's not that simple to figure out what
constitutes personality and what
constitutes something else but so I'm
going to hit at it from a couple of
different perspectives and while I'm
doing so I would like you also to
consider the nature of what you're going
to learn a human personality is
essentially unfathomable human beings
are unbelievably complicated and and
we're nested in systems that are also
unbelievably complicated there are more
patterns of connections between neurons
in your
brain then there are subatomic particles
in the universe by a substantial margin
you can look up Gerald Adelman if you
want to find out about that and so it's
not unreasonable to point out that
you're the most complicated thing we
know of by many orders of magnitude and
the probability that you can understand
yourself in anything approaching
totality is extraordinarily low so this
makes the study of personality something
very daring and hopeless and complicated
now we're going to cycle through a very
large number of theorists and what
you'll find is that although there are
commonalities between them there are
market differences and so then you might
ask yourself well what's the point of
studying this sequence of theorists and
ideas if there's no point of agreement
between them and I would say first there
are points of agreement between them
although personality hasn't advanced to
the point where I would say that we have
a homogeneous theory that's free of
internal contradictions but I would also
say that personality is a hybrid
discipline it's partly science but it's
partly engineering the clinical element
of it I would say is more like
engineering and what engineers do is try
to do things they try to make something
happen and they are informed by theory
but the point is still to build
something and when you're working as a
clinical psychologist and most of the
initial fears that we'll discuss for the
first little more than a third to a half
of the course or clinical theorists
they're trying to build something and
they're dealing with very very difficult
conceptual problems
because they're either trying to cure
mental disorders or maybe even
unhappiness and trying to bring about
health and the problem with that is that
it's not a straightforward thing to
define a mental disorder from a
scientific perspective because what's
healthy mentally and what's not is
partly social judgment and it's partly
socially constructed and it partly has
to do with norms and it partly has to do
with ideals because you might also say
that to be healthy is to be normal but
you could also say that to be healthy is
to be ideal and then of course you run
into the problem of having to
conceptualize an ideal and it isn't
self-evident that science is capable of
conceptualizing an ideal because ideals
tend to fall into the domain of moral
judgments say or philosophical judgments
rather than scientific judgments per se
so what I would say to you is that it
would be worthwhile to approach this
course as if you were an engineer of the
human spirit an engineer of your own
spirit to begin with but also an
engineer of the spirits of other people
because as you interact with other
people you inevitably tell them what you
want and what you don't want when they
give you what you want and what you
admire you respond positively to them
you pay attention to them you smile at
them you focus you focus your thoughts
on them you interact with them and you
reward them for acting in a particular
manner and when they don't respond the
way that you want then you punish them
with a look or by turning away or by
rejecting their friendship or when
you're a child by refusing to play for
them play with them
and so we're engaged in the co-creation
of personalities our own and others and
that also brings up the same question
what is it that we are all collectively
trying to be and trying to create I
suspect that you all have the experience
of falling short of the ideal an ideal
that you hold for yourself or an ideal
that other people hold for you I suspect
that you all feel the negative
consequences of falling short of that
ideal Freud would conceptualize that as
the super-ego imposing its judgment on
the ego you being the ego the super-ego
being a hybrid I suppose of external
forces and also your internalization of
those judgments and forces now
personality per se I would say has these
elements of ideal and has structural
elements of the way as well and we're
going to talk about those more in the
second half of the class the structural
elements can be lined up and outlined
more scientifically the second half of
the class concentrates more on
physiology brain physiology and on
statistical approaches to the
description of personality I suppose you
might say that that outlines the
territory the course is called
personality and its transformations
because we have personalities that's who
you are now but our personalities are
also capable of transformation of change
I mean obviously we think about that is
learning some of that might be regarded
as
factual learning and some of it might be
regarded as learning how to perceive and
behave and I would say that the clinical
psychologists that will cover to begin
with are much more concerned with the
nature of the implicit structures that
shape your perceptions and also the
implicit structures that shape your
behaviors and how they're integrated in
relationship to your negative emotion
health and well-being whereas the
thinkers in the second half are more
concerned about laying out the
structural elements of those features
and relating them to underlying se
mechanistic phenomena making the
Assumption which seems warranted that
there's some relationship between your
personality and the manner in which your
brain functions I'm going to try to
provide you with a meta-narrative that
will help you unite these different
theories I've often found it useful when
I'm trying to remember something to have
a story to hang the facts on otherwise
you're faced with the necessity of doing
nothing but memorization and it isn't
obvious to me that memorization actually
constitutes knowledge what constitutes
knowledge is the generation of a
cognitive structure that enables you to
conduct yourself more appropriately in
life and so I suppose you might say that
of course in psychology you could argue
that a course in psychology especially
in personality is a course in Applied
wisdom as well assuming that wisdom is
in part your capacity to understand
yourselves so that you don't so that you
don't present too much of an intolerable
mystery to yourself and also to
understand others so that you can
predict their behavior understand their
motivations negotiate with them
listen to them and formulate joint games
with them so that you can integrate
yourself reasonably well with another
person and with a family and in society
well the structural elements of
personality might be regarded as the
implicit structures that govern your
perception and that tilt you towards
certain kinds of behaviors I can give
you some examples we can talk about the
Big Five model just briefly the Big Five
personality model is a statistical model
which we'll cover in detail trade by
trade partner partly during the second
half of the course the way that the Big
Five was generated was that its tread
being generated over about 50 years that
personality psychologists gathered
together adjectives with in the English
language first that were used to
describe human beings as many adjectives
as they could collect and then subjected
them to a process called factor analysis
and what factor analysis does is enable
you statistically to determine in some
sense how similar adjectives are to one
another so for example if you gave 1,000
people a list of adjectives to describe
themselves with and one of the
adjectives was happy and another of the
adjectives was social you'd find that
those who rated themselves high unhappy
would also rate themselves high on
social and those who rated themselves
low unhappy would also rate themselves
low on social and by looking at those
patterns of covariation you can
determine what the essential dimensions
are of human personality one of the
dimensions is roughly happiness that's
extraversion another dimension is
neuroticism it's a negative emotion
dimension so if you ask someone if
they're anxious and they score high say
on a scale of 1 to 7 they're also likely
to score
on another item that says that they're
sad and it turns out that negative
emotions clump together and so that
people who experience more of one
negative emotion have a propensity to
experience more of all of them there's
another dimension called agreeableness
and agreeable people are
self-sacrificing compassionate and
polite if you're dealing with an
agreeable person they don't like
conflict they care for other people if
you're dealing with an agreeable person
they're likely to put your concerns
ahead of theirs they're non competitive
and cooperative it's a dimension where
women are women score more highly than
men on agreeableness across cultures
including those cultures where the
largest steps have been taken towards
producing an egalitarian social
circumstance like Scandinavia actually
the gender differences in personality
there are larger than they are anywhere
else another trait is conscientiousness
conscientiousness is an excellent trait
if you want to do well in in school and
in work especially if you're a manager
an administrator I can't say we
understand a lot about conscientiousness
although it it reliably emerges from
factor analytic studies of adjectives
groups across different countries
conscientious people are diligent
industrious and orderly they're
orderliness tilts them towards political
conservatism by the way because it turns
out that your inbuilt
temperament your inbuilt personality
which constitutes a set of filters
through which you view the world also
alters the manner in which you process
information and influences the way that
you vote and so you might say and I do
believe that this is true or we've been
doing a lot of research on this as of
late the more accurate a measure you
take of someone's political beliefs the
more you find that personality is what's
predicting them and I think that's a
reasonable thing to think about because
you know you have to you have to figure
out ways of simplifying the world right
because you just can't do everything and
so
people are specialized they have
specialized niches that they occupy you
can think about them as social niches
can niche is a place where your
particular skills would serve to
maintain you and so if you're
extroverted you're going to look for a
social niche because you like to be
around people and if you're introverted
you're going to spend much more time on
your own and so if you're an introverted
person for example you're going to want
a job where you're not selling and where
you're not surrounded by groups of
people who are making social demands on
you all the time because it'll wear you
out
whereas if you're extroverted that's
just exactly what you want and so the
extrovert sees the world as a place of
social opportunity and the introvert
sees the world as a place to retreat
from and spend time alone and it turns
out that both of those modes of being
are valid that the issue at least to
some degree is whether or not you're
fortunate enough to match your
temperament with the demands of the
environment and I suppose also whether
you're fortunate enough fortunate enough
so that you're born in an era where
there actually is a niche for your
particular temperament because it isn't
necessarily the case that that will be
the case
imagine that all of these temperamental
dimensions vary because of evolutionary
pressure right so there's a distribution
of extraversion a normal distribution
most people are somewhere in the middle
and then as you go out towards the
extremes there are fewer and fewer
people and what that means is that on
average across large spans of time there
have been environments that match every
single position on that distribution
with most most of the environments
matching the center because otherwise we
wouldn't have evolved that way and so
sometimes being really extroverted is
going to work well for you in a minority
of environments a minority of niches and
sometimes it's just going to be a
catastrophe I suspect for example that
if you live in a tyrannical society
where any sign of of personally oriented
activity is likely to get you in trouble
that being extroverted and low in
neuroticism would it be a very good idea
because you're gonna be mouthy and happy
and saying a lot of things unable to
keep your thoughts to yourself and
you're going to be relatively
fearless now I don't know that for sure
because we've haven't done the studies
that precisely match temperamental
proclivity to environmental demand but
you get what I mean
so conscientious people anyways
conscientious people are industrious and
orderly we know a little bit about
orderliness it seems to be associated
strangely enough with disgust
sensitivity which I suppose isn't that
surprising you know if you take an
orderly person then you put them in a
messy kitchen they respond with disgust
and want nothing more than to straighten
it all out and organize it and clean it
and there's tremendous variability and
orderliness and as I said orderliness
predicts political conservatism it's not
the only thing but it's certainly one of
the things the correlation between
conscientiousness and and grades is
about 0.4 it's about 16% of the variance
it's it's the second best predictor of
university grades after intelligence and
we'll talk about intelligence during
this course too intelligence is actually
a relatively straightforward concept I
don't think I'll get into it today but
conscientious people they're
industriousness and they're orderliness
makes them schedule their time so they
make efficient use of their time they
use schedules and that sort of thing we
haven't been able to figure out anything
about the underlying biology or
psychology of industriousness we've
tried really dozens and dozens of tests
attempting to find a laboratory measure
on which industrious people do better
and we failed completely and there's no
animal models of industriousness either
and so I would say it's a great mystery
that remains at the heart of trait
psychology and maybe it's a human
specific category you know I mean you
can think of sled dogs maybe of being
industrious and maybe and maybe sheep
dogs and animals that work like that but
of course they've been trained by human
beings so but it isn't obvious that
animals are industrious the same way we
are
I mean industriousness involves
sacrificing the present for the future
something like that and you seems like
you have to be able to conceptualize
time in order to sacrifice the present
for the future one of the things that I
would recommend that you do as students
in this course and maybe in every course
speaking of industriousness is come up
with a plan of attack for the course and
use a scheduler you know if you treat
your university career like a full-time
job you're much more likely to succeed
and if you keep up on the readings and
you keep up on the on the essays and all
of that then you're much less likely as
well to fall into despair when you get
too far behind using a Google Calendar
or something like that to organize a
schedule for the entire semester at the
beginning of the semester can be
invaluable especially if you're not very
industriousness very industrious because
it can keep you on track and one of the
things we know about industrious people
is that they are very good at using
schedules and at planning the use of
their time and so I would like to say
that you should all be smarter but I
don't know how you could be smarter we
don't know anything about how to improve
intelligence and I suppose we don't
really know anything about how to
improve industriousness either but I can
tell you that people who are industrious
come up with a strategy for solving the
problem that's ahead of them and then
they do whatever they can to stick to
the strategy and so for example if you
sat down today or tomorrow for a couple
of hours three hours and you filled in a
google calendar whatever you happen to
use with a strategy for studying and a
list of when all your assignments are
due and all of that and when you're
going to sit down and study then you
won't be in a position where you have to
cram for 10 hours a day hopelessly right
before you know an important exam it's
also a very ineffective way of studying
by the way I mean first of all people
who cram for 10 hours say they're
studying for 10 hours but they rarely
are because well I can't study for 10
hours I don't have the power of
concentration that would enable me to do
that for that prolonged period of time
I can manage about three hours of
intense intellectual activity before I'm
pretty done and it's also the case that
if you study and then sleep and then
study and then sleep and then study and
then sleep
you space it out then you're much more
likely to remember it's also much more
likely that you're you're much more
likely to remember if you try to recall
the material and so highlighting and
that sort of thing isn't very useful but
reading closing the book summarizing
what you've read without opening the
damn book that's useful and the reason
for that is that you're practicing
remembering and that's what you have to
practice if you're practicing
memorization you have to practice
remembering you don't just go over the
thing over and over
that'll help you with recognition memory
but some but it won't help you with
recall memory so anyways the last trade
is openness openness is a creativity
trait it's also associated with
intelligence in that intelligent people
and I'm speaking technically of IQ tend
to be higher and tend to be more
creative which is hardly surprising
creative people are more likely to be
liberal politically by the way they like
novelty they like aesthetics they like
fiction they like movies they like art
they like poetry there is something
about them that grants them an aesthetic
sensitivity and and that's a that's an
inbuilt trait and it's not the case by
the way that everyone's creative in fact
far from it we've used the creative
achievement questionnaire to to measure
people's creativity I'll talk to you
about that later in the class and the
creative achievement questionnaire takes
13 dimensions of creativity so you know
writing dancing acting scientific
investigation entrepreneurial activity
architectural activity cooking there's a
there's a handful of others singing etc
you know the sorts of things that you
would assume that people could be
creative about and then it asks people
to rate themselves on a scale from one
to ten on their level of achievement
with regards to all those creative
domains with zero being I have no
training or proficiency in this area and
70% of people score zero across the
entire creative achievement
questionnaire a tiny proportion of
people are outliers way out and they're
creative in many dimensions
simultaneously and it
exceptionally creative and it turns out
as you'll find out that that pattern
which is called a Pareto distribution
where most people stack up at zero and a
few people are way out on the creative
end characterizes all sorts of
distributions like the distribution of
money for example which is why 1% of the
people have the overwhelming majority of
the money it's a different 1% across
time it like it churns and you're much
more likely to be in the 1% if you're
older logically enough because one of
the things you do as you age is you
trade youth for money if you're
fortunate I don't think the trade is
really worth it but that's the best
you've got so anyways those particular
traits you can think of those as ways
that you simplify the world right
there's lots of different places that
you can act in the world and there's
lots of different ways you can look at
it and survive that's why you can be a
plumber and a lawyer and an engineer and
those all work right even though they're
very different modes of being and you
can have different personalities and
survive as long as you're capable of
finding the place where your particular
filters and behavioral proclivities
match the demand of the environment and
a huge part I would say of successful
adaptation is precisely that now there
are other elements of personality too
one of the things that I've been struck
by and this is actually one of the
criticisms I have of the psycho analysts
and the clinicians in general even
though I have great admiration for them
and would say that what they have to say
is very much worth listening to is that
it's not obvious that your personality
is inside you you know what you think
you know a human being is a strange
multi-level thing and you might ask
yourself well for example
know is your mother more a part of you
than your arm or maybe even more
precisely is your child more a part of
you than your arm it's certainly people
will do drastically self-sacrificing
things to maintain the lives of their
children and so you're you're a person
and you're made out of all sub
sort of subcomponents of a person none
of which you could see when you look at
a person all the complicated machinery
inside you that makes you who you are
and then outside of that of course
you're nested in all sorts of complex
systems so you're part of a family and
and you're part of a community and
that's part of a province and that's
part of the state and that's part of an
international consortium of states and
that's part of an ecosystem and how you
make a distinction between you and the
systems that you're embedded in is also
of extraordinary difficulty and when it
and one of the things that you have to
do as a clinical psychologist for
example if you're trying to diagnose
someone with depression you think you
think well this person's dreadfully
unhappy well you can think about that as
a problem with their psychological
adjustment you know the way that they're
looking at the world but if you look at
the epidemiological literature for
example one of the things that you find
is that very many people have a first
depressive episode after something
genuinely terrible has happened to them
right they've lost someone or they've
become injured or or they've become
unemployed because unemployment is a
terrible shock to people and it's not
precisely self-evident that you can
consider someone who's unhappy and
desperate because they no longer have a
job depressed they're certainly sad and
they're not doing very well but the fact
that they no longer have an income is
actually something with dramatic
practical consequences and treating that
as if it's a mental disorder seems to be
counterproductive it's also the case for
example that if you're if someone comes
into you to talk to you and they're very
upset and they may manifest the signs of
say an anxiety disorder or again
depression or other other clinical
features for that matter you have to do
a careful analysis of their manner in
which they're embedded in their family
because and this is something that we'll
talk about quite thoroughly when we come
to discussing Freud is that well you
know it's not like everybody's families
are necessarily particularly happy
places to be
you know I mean human beings are very
dependent we have a very long period of
dependency partly because we're so
cortically hyperdeveloped it takes a
very long time to program us into
something that's vaguely capable of
maneuvering on its own and that produces
of course the very tight familial bonds
that we all that we all desperately
require because who wants to be alone in
the world but it also it also exposes us
to the probability of becoming entangled
into even multi-generational family
pathology and it isn't obvious always
uncertainty hasn't been to me when I've
seen my clients that the fundamental
problem with the client is the client
sometimes the fundamental problem is is
the family and and perhaps that person
has been identified as the problem
person it's rather convenient for
everyone who's involved to make that
presupposition it's also the case that
this is the Freudian idea fundamentally
this is the Oedipal idea that it's very
easy for people to become over dependent
on their parents and and for the parents
to facilitate that and then for the
primary developmental problem for the
individual in fact to become free of the
interfering elements of the family so
that they can exist as independent
individuals well and then of course
there are cultural variations in that
that make that proposition complex but
that's a fundamental tenant say of
Freudian psychology a lot of the
clinical psychologists all of whom that
we're going to study have a pronounced
Western orientation one of the
fundamental presuppositions is that part
of the hallmark of positive
psychological development is the
creation of an individual that's capable
of acting independently and that's I
would say an implicit ideal that lurks
at the bottom of the clinical
presuppositions of all the theorists
that are classic psychologists
so now it's a very old picture it's
Jonah
emerging from the whale it's a variant
of a myth the myth is the dragon myth I
suppose the dragon myth is that there's
a dragon that lives under the ground
that's eternal and now and then it rises
out of the ground to threaten the state
and someone within the state determines
to go confront the dragon voluntarily
and does so and then brings back
something of great value sometimes if
the the the hero is generally male
sometimes the thing of great value is a
female that the dragon has kidnapped
that's a st. George story and sometimes
it's gold another treasure like in the
story of The Hobbit and story that you
all know very well it's a classic hero
story and the hero story is another
fundamental element of the clinical
theories I would say it's predicated on
the idea that you learn through
voluntary contact with that that
frightens or disgusts you and that's a
hallmark of psychoanalytic theory Jung,
Carl Jung who we'll discuss in detail
said his primary dictum was“In
sterquiliniis invenitur” which I'm sure I'm
massacring because it's Latin but it
meant ”in filth it will be found” and one
of the hallmarks of the clinical
theories is that within the confines of
everyone's experience and you can think
about this as experience out in the
world or experience in the unconscious
mind there are dirty little secrets
let's say and skeletons and dreadful old
fears and remnants of abuse and memories
of pathological behavior and failures of
courage that you leave you undeveloped
perhaps out of avoidance and that the
psychoanalytic process is precisely the
careful encounter with those forgotten
and and repressed elements of the self
in the hope that a clear encounter will
redeem them unites them with the
remainder of your personality and make
yours make you stronger in consequence
and I would say that that's just a
variant of the manner in which human
beings learn and we'll talk about this
more in relationship to Piaget because
you always learn when you're wrong which
is very annoying now what do you learn
when you're correct you you're walking
in the world you're operating in the
world you have a sense of what you want
to have happen you're always looking at
the world through this sense of what you
want to have happen you're acting so
that what you want to have happen will
happen and when it happens well then
you're happy because well first of all
you get what you want and that's good
maybe depending on what you want but
it's also good because if you get what
you want when you act then it turns out
that your model of how to act is valid
right the outcome that you get what you
want
indicates no error on the part of your
model but it's very frequently the case
that when you act to get what you want
you don't get what you want and then
that's unpleasant because you don't get
what you want but it's even more
unpleasant because it brings with it the
hint of a suggestion that the manner in
which you're construing the world is
incorrect at some indeterminate level so
for example if you tell a party tell a
joke at a party you presume that people
will attend and then when they hear the
joke they will laugh and then if you
tell the joke and it goes flat or even
worse disgusts and offends people then
you're going to be taken aback and
that's partly because you didn't get
what you want and that's not so good but
it's but it's more because there's
something wrong with the way you
conceptualized the situation and then
you're faced with a problem and the
problem is the emergence of a domain of
the unknown it's like well what kind of
mistake did you make
maybe you're not as funny as you think
you are not that could be a big problem
maybe you're not around people that who
are the way you think they are maybe
they don't like you as much as you
thought they liked you I mean the
potential for various paranoid thoughts
of increasing severity to come welling
up at you in a situation where you make
even a trivial social mistake is quite
broad and when you make an error of that
sort you have to face it and sort
through all the possibilities so that
you can find out what it was that you
did wrong and how to retool it so that
in the future you don't make the same
mistake and that requires well that
requires in some sense what you might
describe as a journey into the belly of
the beast the beast being that place
where things have fallen apart and where
you're overwhelmed with negative emotion
and chaos and confusion and that's a
very old story that's the story of the
journey to the underworld and the hero
is the person who makes the voluntary
journey to the underworld to collect
what's been languishing down there and
that's the basic motif of psychoanalytic
theory I would say it's the basic motif
in some sense of clinical practice
because one of the things that you do as
a clinician is find out what people are
afraid of and what they're avoiding and
that can be in their past or in their
present or in their future break it down
into smaller pieces and help them devise
strategies of approach and mastery and
that improves the quality of their
personality and helps develop them into
people who won't make the same mistakes
over and over again all right so well
why these this plethora of tools well I
said in some sense being a personality
psychologist is like being an engineer
you're trying to build better people
when you might say that if you're a
carpenter or a mechanic that your
ability to fix a vehicle or build a
house is dependent on your proficiency
with regards to the use of a multitude
of tools and so then you might say well
the more tools you have at your disposal
the more likely it is that you're going
to manage things properly and so what I
would like to offer you is the
possibility that what you're going to
encounter in this course is a series of
sophisticated conceptual tools that will
help you understand yourself better and
therefore better orient yourself in the
world I regard this course as intensely
practical and that's because I believe
that you have nothing to rely on in your
life that's more crucial to your success
as you move through life than your
character and your personality that's
what you bring to every situation and
the more sophisticated you are in
relationship to yourself and others the
more you understand people the deeper
you understand the nature of your own
being the more likely it is that you're
going to proceed through your life in a
manner that will make you pleased to
exist rather than displeased to exist
I've collected the writings of people
that I regard as of incomparable
brilliance they're difficult to
understand their concepts are complex
but it's not surprising because the
subject matter is complex and vital and
so it requires work and I would say try
to keep up on the readings if you would
it's going to make the course much more
much richer for you and I would say
because people often ask me well how
should I read for this course because
there's a lot of reading and the answer
is read as if it matters that's the
right answer
don't be thinking about how it's going
to be tested if you do the readings and
you come to the lectures then
the tests aren't particularly difficult
but you should read the readings as if
the person is writing about you and you
should try to understand what the person
says because it's another tool for you
to use and I would say well with my
clients you know I used the approaches
of one theorist for one client and the
approaches of another theorist for
another client it seems to me to depend
to some degree actually on the
temperament of the client I found for
example that people who are very high in
openness which is the creativity
dimension are quite amenable to a
Jungian approach whereas people who are
more practical conscientious lowe and
openness are much more amenable to a
behaviorist approach we don't really
know enough about psychology yet to
match treatment to temperament but those
are the some of the things that I've
experienced ok practicalities well
there's a website I gave you the URL
I'll put it up again at the end of class
the URL lists all the readings that
aren't in the textbook and so the
textbook contains the classic readings
readings from people like Jung and Freud
and Piaget and so forth Rogers and as I
said I picked that particular textbook
because I believe that the author did a
very credible job of summarizing what's
very difficult to summarize so and then
also on the website there are links to
papers because much of the more modern
material that pertains say to
neuroscience and also to trait
personality I think it's better just to
read the original papers and I'll detail
them out with you as we go through and
that'll also give you some familiarity
with original psychological papers which
are again there's a there's an idiom
that you have to master in order to
understand them but you might as well
practice it especially if you're
interested in continuing with psychology
in your educational practice or as a
career it's good to get accustomed to it
so
there again is the URL for the class if
you go to Jordan be Peterson comm which
isn't too hard to remember
assuming you can remember my name then
classes are listed on the left hand side
you can just find the syllabus there
alright so here's what we're going to
cover well today obviously this is the
introduction and overview the class is a
little strange this year because one day
it's an hour and the next day it's two
hours so not exactly sure how we're
going to negotiate our way through that
but we'll figure it out
historical perspectives mythological
representations well I told you that I
would try to provide you with a
meta-narrative that might enable you to
link the theories that we're going to
talk about together so I'm going to
describe to you what you might regard as
a conceptual language and as far as I
can tell it's that imagine imagine that
there are two kinds of things that you
need to know and I believe this to be
the case I believe that you need to know
what the world is made of and I suppose
that's the proper domain of science but
then you need to know how to act and
that's a whole different thing and you
need to know how to act that's the thing
you need to know most of anything
anything because of course you're a
living creature and action in
relationship to desired goals is is
everything to you and you can think
about that from a Darwinian perspective
you have to act at least so that you can
survive at least so that you can find a
partner that's that's life and so part
of the question is well how does the
world look if you think about it as a
place to act and the answer isn't a
place of value free objects that's not
what the world looks like and you can't
act in a world of value free objects
because there's no way of choosing
between them if everything has zero
value why would you choose one thing
over another you live in a world where
things present themselves to you as of
different value and that's partly a
consequence of your temperament although
it's a consequence of other things and
so what I'm going to try to do is to
provide you with
schema that describes the world of
morality roughly speaking which is how
to act and tell you a little bit about
what I think the languages which I think
was derived from Darwinian processes and
I believe that it's within that
structure that the clinical theories
logically nest and so that'll give you a
way of linking one theory to another
from a conceptual perspective without
having to rely so much on sheer
memorization then we'll talk about
heroic and shamanic initiation and the
reason we're going to do that is because
well people people used shamanic
initiation for tens of thousands of
years all over the world and they have a
particular kind of structure the paper
by merchant Le ADA which is linked on
the site is a very interesting one and
details out some of these processes
there have been intelligent commentators
like Andre Ellenberger Burge a who wrote
the discovery of the unconscious which i
think is an outstanding book who late
the processes that the psychoanalyst
psychoanalysts uncovered in the late
part of the 19th century an early part
of the 20th century back to these more
primordial rituals of personality
transformation and so we're going to
situate ourselves in some sense in deep
history talking first about the
underlying mythological landscape then
talking about archaic modes of
personality conceptualization and
transformation and then moving from
there into constructivism and and we're
going to concentrate mostly on Jean
Piaget who is a developmental
psychologist constructivists believed
that you make yourself out of the
information that you gather in the world
so you're an exploring creature you
explore specifically when the maps that
you're using in the world are no longer
orienting yourself properly when they're
producing errors so you go out and
gather information and assemble yourself
from the information that you discovered
then the depth psychologists Jung and
Freud I think I'm going to with Jung I'm
going to walk you through some films I'm
not going to use the film's per se I'm
going to use Clips stills from the film
but
in you know the film so in in
chronological order and I'm going to try
to explain to you how you might use
Union presuppositions to understand what
the films are about you know if you
think about a film say like The Lion
King which is an extraordinarily popular
film it's a very strange phenomena that
you go and watch it right I mean think
about it
it's drawings of animated animals that
in some sense represent you they're very
low resolution but you perceive them
immediately as living things and you
attribute to the motivation and and and
motive power and understanding you do it
automatically without even thinking
about it and there's a classic plot that
lies underneath those stories and the
plots are very very very very old and
that's why you can understand them and
the reason you can understand them is
because life has a plot or maybe it has
a couple of plots a multitude of plots
but life has a plot and if it didn't we
wouldn't be able to understand each
other and so I'd like to illustrate that
for you by analysis of some of these
films I think it's the best way to
understand someone as sophisticated as
young who is very difficult to get a
handle on Freud I'm going to do the same
thing all the way I'm going to show you
a film with Freud I'm going to show you
a film called crumb which is a
documentary and it's about a very badly
enmeshed family and the attempts of the
family members to I suppose escape that
I'll talk to you about Freud I'll show
you the film that should give you a
sense of Freudian psychopathology which
is a very difficult thing otherwise to
understand then there's a midterm a
midterm is multiple-choice you'll do it
in class you'll have lots of time to
finish it it'll cover the material that
we took that we studied up to that point
then we're going to talk about Rogers
Carl Rogers who was a humanist Rogers
has a body-centered philosophy I suppose
and he's interested as well in optimal
personal development and the role that
interpersonal communication plays in
that Rogers hypothesis fundamentally and
it's a very interesting one is that
honest communication between two people
can produce personnel
transformation and and you know you
might think well you kind of know that
already because there's something very
engaging about a deep honest
conversation where you're able to say
things that you wouldn't normally say
where you're being listened to by
someone who's actually listening to you
and you're listening to them and in the
conversation you're moving both of you
further to a different point that's
different than a conversation where
you're right and you're trying to
convince me or I'm right and I'm trying
to convince you which I would say is the
typical conversation the the healing
conversation is more well what's up with
you you know how are you doing what how
is your life going where what sort of
problems are you facing what do you
think about those problems can you
conceptualize what a solution might be
is there a way we could figure out how
to get there you know what's so it's a
problem-solving conversation and it's
predicated on the presupposition that
the person that you're conversing with
has the capacity to grow in a positive
direction if they so choose that's the
fundamental that's the fundamental
presupposition of Rogerian psychology
man Frankel are also humanists all
finish tell you what the rest of the the
rest of the material is the next time
that we meet I should show you let you
know a little bit more about the
structure of course the second midterm
is March 14th the and there's a final at
the end as well so the mid the
multiple-choice tests are graded in that
manner 25% 25% in 27.5% they're not
cumulative each test only covers what
you covered before since the last test
including the final you'll be required
to write an essay of 15% it's a thousand
words sorry not 750 words and you'll
also do an online exercise a personality
analysis which is pass/fail all you have
to do is complete it and show proof of
completion it helps you do a modified
Big Five analysis of your own
personality concentrating on your
virtues and your faults so that so so
it's a it's an active exercise in the
application of personality theory to
personal development and so that's the
that's the structure of the course I can
tell you there's a sign-up sheet on the
on the syllabus we I've broken the
essays down into multiple types across
the entire semester I would highly
recommend that you go there and sign up
there are limited slots for each topic
and the reason for that is well I don't
want my TA to have to grade 200 essays
the last week of classes we have to
spread them out across the year so
figure out a topic and sign out please
and please do that sooner rather than
later it's it's an industrious thing to
do it'll help you organize yourself I'll
post something that's quite useful about
how to write especially a thousand word
essay and I'll close the essays are due
one day before class I'll close by the
way by telling you who shouldn't take
this course okay first of all if you
didn't like this lecture and don't take
this course because this is what the
lectures are going to be like so and
it's they're not for everybody
oh you used a lot of loose associations
and try to gather them back in and I
kind of wander around that way I can
talk directly to you which I like doing
but I sacrifice a certain amount of
organization for that but my sense is
that it's worth the sacrifice the second
thing is there's a lot of reading a lot
and a lot of it is I would say a lot of
it's hard science the last half in
particular but the first half of a lot
of its philosophical in nature
philosophical / psychological and so if
you're not interested in that
like if you're a pure science type and
you're not interested in the clinical
elements say of personality and in the
end in investigating the philosophical
underpinnings of those clinical theories
then I would say this isn't the course
for you and so you should take that
seriously because the readings are hard
there's a lot of work involved in this
course and it would be better if you
took a course that you actually wanted
to take so well welcome to psychology
230 and we'll see you in a bit
you